most of the surprises in fast X will
make audience members gasp or cackle but
one Cameo is sure to bring a tear to the
eyes of fans who recognize the actress
playing the role it's all about family
some spoilers for fast decks ahead fastx
is loaded with so many mind-blowing
returns cameos and resurrections it's
almost hard to keep track from the
bizarre inclusion of comedian Pete
Davidson to the shocking comeback of
Dwayne The Rock Johnson as Lou Cobbs
there are plenty of faces old and new to
stir feelings of nostalgia in the
franchise's die-hard fans one Cameo
appearance however has a Sentimental
meaning not everyone watching might
catch around the midpoint of the film
Jacob Toretto and Little Brian find
themselves on the run from the agency
that once protected them so Uncle Jacob
your dad sent me in the absence of both
Mr Nobody and little nobody agent Ames
claims to believe that Dominic Toretto
and his crew are responsible for an
explosive car chase in Rome in reality
he's secretly working with Dante Reyes
and has been since the events of Fast
Five
part of Jacob and Little B's Journey
sees them working with a commercial
airline attendant to escape their agency
tale that very flight attendant is
played by Meadow Rain Walker the
daughter of the late actor and Fast and
Furious star Paul Walker as longtime
fans of the franchise know Walker died
in a tragic accident in 2013 while
Furious 7 was still in production
understandably the cast and crew were
devastated and have sought to keep his
memory alive in their own way by
maintaining his presence within the fast
Saga Dom's son introduced in the fate of
the Furious is even named after Walker's
character Brian O'Connor Meadow was just
a year old when the actor starred in
2001's The Fast and the Furious now
making her feature film debut in fast X
Meadow took to Instagram to talk about
her experience growing up within the
fast Saga she wrote I grew up on set
watching my father Vin Diesel Jordana
Brewster Michelle Rodriguez Chris
Ludacris Bridges and more on the
monitors thanks to my dad I was born
into the fast family I can't believe now
I get to be up there too she went on to
think fastx director Louis literier for
bringing her on board and for giving her
a chance to pay tribute to Paul Walker
on screen writing I am so blessed to be
able to honor my father's Legacy and
share this with him forever
playing Jacob's life-saving Airline
acquaintance isn't the only way Meadow
is preserving her father's memory she
has spent nearly the last decade trying
to make the world a better place in his
name when not helping the toretos to
defeat their latest foe Meadow works as
a model and philanthropic Ambassador
Walker works with numerous charitable
organizations including the United
Nations population fund a human rights
organization dedicated to Global
reproductive health and safety she also
works with a marine conservation
non-profit in Oceana and the global
education organization pencils of
Promise in 2015 she founded the Paul
Walker Foundation which provides
scholarships and grant money to students
working in Marine and environmental
Sciences to this day she serves as the
foundation's chief executive officer
in 2021 Meadow married actor Louis
Thornton Allen at their wedding she was
walked down the aisle by her Godfather
Vin Diesel at the premiere of fast decks
in Rome Meadow attended and walked the
red carpet it was a cool way to connect
with my dad and I'm really excited about
that on Instagram she called appearing
in this film a once in a lifetime
experience